keeping kiev's biggest Dairy Factory
running isn't easy when Russia invaded
Ukraine and tried to capture the city
last year staff slept on site for weeks
to keep production going amid shelling
and curfews now it's power cuts that are
disrupting business
from 10 o'clock in the morning to five
in the afternoon we only have a quarter
of our electricity needs and only half
in the evening but we need continuous
power for 14 hours to be able to
complete one milk production cycle
to make up for the shortages the
factories had to adapt managers of
reduced output and staff now pack in the
day and process the milk overnight
before the war all the machines in this
Factory would have been running 24 hours
a day now the majority have to be
switched on at night when consumption
elsewhere in the city is at its lowest
repeated Russian attacks on energy
facilities in Ukraine are straining the
grid and making life even more difficult
for people and businesses with cold
winter weather only compounding the
problem it's not a special operation
it's terrorism it's genocide of
population in Ukraine it's Russians try
to destroy the critical infrastructure
they try to let population Ukraine to
live without heating electricity and
water in Winter condition where when
outside is minus 10 degrees Celsius 20
degrees Celsius
for many companies generators provide a
Lifeline this Craft brewery on the
outskirts the city couldn't operate
without one
is up costs but at least the company's
production of beers and soft drinks
isn't affected I think the key
characteristic of Ukrainian people is
that we are Fighters when someone fight
us we fight back and we find the ways to
live to work and to to make our lives
better
determined and resourceful the war may
be battering Ukraine's economy but
despite the cracks and the challenges
some businesses are finding ways to stay
afloat Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Kiev